you've had so many health problems
you're now you know
i know close to 80 or something and
you always see yourself as a guy running
out of time
well you know i am at the end of my life
howard and it's a very strange thing and
here's what i've come to about it
it's not how much time you got because
we really don't know uh
i i could have two weeks i could have
ten years it's
what you do with the time that you do
have
and so i'm trying to really spend it
well whatever
each day that i get i'm very grateful
for and i try to
do it making music because i think the
world needs music how is your health
like uh i know you suffer from
surprisingly good man it's
nothing's broken yet i'm waiting
i am losing my ability to play guitar
that's kind of
tough you've got tendinitis from both
hands so what happens when you play
your hands hurt your fingers get your
fingers stop being able to
like the see the middle finger there
that one won't won't close all the way
or open other way it won't open more
than that
and they get uh they have trouble doing
the picking thing that's my thing
that's what i do you know i got another
year or so of being able to play and i'm
i can teach my parts to somebody else if
i really want to play
that bad uh i can't i can play piano
though
i don't know if i'm gonna play anymore
you think i ought to
listen with you i feel like it's also
you're a storyteller you're not it's not
necessarily about your guitar prowess
it's your whole vibe to me you have to
keep going on and plus i think it would
kill you if you stop
making music on the news you'll make a
record so i got this record
man i'm so glad you like it hey listen
to this song a little bit i'll play some
of it it just feels like the
the words of a man who's contemplating
the end of life it makes me want to cry
when i listen to it
me too you nailed me with it every time
two three i'm standing on the porch
like it's the edge of a cliff
[Music]
beyond the grass and gravel
the reason it gets me too is because i
don't want to lose you
i love you so much i love your music i
admire you as a musician um
it's unbearable to hear that song almost
well don't don't
let it be unbearable man uh people get
old and die
and that's how that's how it works and
i'm gonna uh
but in the meantime i'm gonna have
myself a bunch of fun i guarantee it
because i have a phd in fun
as you well know yes and i'm going to
make some more music because i love
doing it i know that i'm supposed to
you know quietly shuffle off into the
distance but
i'm not gonna i've got two more records
planned
and i won't stay for long